le tout petit bout dans le contexte
qu'on vit en ce moment dans cette crise
d'ebola qu'est ce que les compagnies
aériennes peuvent et doivent faire les
compagnies aériennes n'étant pas des
spécialistes en santé publique se fie
beaucoup sur les recommandations des
autorités de santé publique
et comme il s'agit de haut niveau
international nous il ya tant on
travaille étroitement avec l'oms
l'organisation mondiale de la santé et
est aussi beaucoup avec aux états unis à
ces décès parce qu'ils sont c'est
national mais sont quand même très
impliqué comme vous savez au niveau des
crises de ce type long alors encore
opéra mais que nous aurons donne à nos
compagnies membres des informations des
lignes de conduite à suivre concernant
ce type de crise il ya des compagnies
aériennes par exemple qui ont interrompu
leurs services dans l'afrique de l'ouest
est ce que c'est bien ou est-ce que ça
empire les choses c'est ni bien ni mal
vous savez ce qui arrive c'est que par
exemple lors à metz recommande que
autant que faire se peut que les
compagnies aériennes continuent à offrir
le service
bien entendu ce qui est nouveau
sportster de façon générale par contre
au niveau particulier
chaque compagnie aérienne est en
connaissance de tous les différents
items qui peuvent se servir pour prendre
une décision
alors dans certains cas certaines
compagnies ont dû arrêter parce qu' il
ne pouvait pas rencontrer les besoins
qu'ils avaient pour leurs équipages pour
leurs passagers
alors vous savez des compagnies qui ont
arrêté vous avez des compagnies qui ont
continué parce que pouvaient avoir les
services qu'ils désiraient qu'ils savent
être besoin
alors comme je vous dis c'est nina
allait bien mais il faut qu' il y en a
un certain nombre comme dit l'om est-ce
que transporter les passagers et
l'équipe parce que peut coopérer que
collaborer à a paralysé ces pays là
d'une façon aussi les compagnies
aériennes s'est rompu effectivement si
avait aucun de compagnies aériennes qui
s'y rendaient ça causerait problème
parce que comment transporter les
passagers
les travailleurs humanitaires
les l'information l'équipement etc
mais ce n'est pas le cas actuellement et
je crois pas que ça va devenir parce que
les compagnies qui sont en place sont
bien déterminés à continuer les réformes
qu'est ce que peuvent faire les
compagnies aériennes pour assurer par
exemple les passagers parce que il ya de
l'inquiétude vous savez vous lviv et
puis c'est pour ça que vous êtes très
occupé de ce temps là d'ailleurs
alors qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire
qu'est ce que les compagnies peuvent
faire pour assurer leur personnel mais
aussi les passagers ben pour rassurer le
personnel ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on
établit comme je disais tu auras des
lignes de conduite et de l'information
pour le dire qu'est ce qui est à risque
qu'est-ce qui est pas parce que
évidemment dans cette crise la hausse
conjointe aussi c'est la peur oui ok
alors quand on a de la bonne information
et qu'on a des bonnes lignes de conduite
en général les équipages vont être
d'accord pour poursuivre le service donc
c'est de cette façon là qu'on a et nos
experts pour ce qui est des passagers et
bien évidemment on suit aussi beaucoup
aux autorités de santé publique dans les
divers pays
pour edwy moeurs pour établir ce qui est
adressée ce qui ne l'est pas et pour
essayer de calmer si vous voulez la peur
inhérentes qui existe durant tout ce
type de crise
est ce qu'il ya un côté poney qu'est-ce
qu'on exagère la peur en ce moment
certainement dans certains cas dans
certaines rapport publication on exagère
parce que bon ça fait toujours bien
d'exagérer mais je dois avouer que il ya
beaucoup de place pour les autorités de
santé publique pour les messages
d'information qui se passe je pense que
c'est raisonnable pour le vol est ce
qu'il vaut là c'est la pire crise qu'on
ait connu dans le genre non pas vraiment
mais c'est la pire crise d'ebola en
afrique de l'ouest comme son comparse à
d'autres maladies transmissibles comme
le strass peur c'est oui comme chez
c'est très différent parce que de strass
par exemple il y avait une composante
aérienne alors plus grosse mi saison par
voie aérienne
alors si puis ce qui est beaucoup plus
difficile à contrôler alors que ebola se
transmet uniquement par contacts
personnels avec des liquides biologiques
donc
à ce moment là c'est plus difficile à
transmettre c'est encore possible parce
qu'il sait ça se transmet mais comme
vous voyez en afrique de l'ouest à cause
des pratiques
c'est très difficile à arrêter par conte
dans les camps s'est transmis dans un
autre pays comme aux etats-unis comme en
espagne ben vous voyez que ça s'arrête
assez rapidement parce qu'on peut
circonscrire qu'en faisant en prenant
les mesures qu'il faut quand on a les
infrastructures nécessaires vers
l'afrique de l'ouest actuellement c'est
ça le problème c'est qu'ils me manquent
beaucoup d'infrastructures et puis j'ai
dû très difficile à rater alors
qu'est-ce que des compagnies aériennes
de ces gens qui vont s'asseoir dans un
avion les gens qui nous disent des là là
qu'ils ont peur de prendre à dire que ce
débat là c'est jallet peut pas se
promener avec un thermomètre prendre la
température de leurs voisins dans
l'avion qu'est ce que les compagnies
aériennes doivent dire à ses passagers
tous les rassurer site
bon bah écoutez ça s'applique
principalement évidemment aux passagers
qui vont aller ou qui vont être de
retour des pays affectés
je pense pas que si vous faites un
voyage en asie actuellement qu'il ya un
problème on sache limite plutôt aux
voyageurs qui ont voyagé sur ces pays ou
en provenance de ces pays
à ce moment là qu'est ce qu'on dit aux
voyageurs c'est ce que les autorités de
santé publique dit c'est vous approchez
pas de gens qui sont malades n'allait
pas dans les hôpitaux évidemment où on
traite hezbollah ne touchez pas aux
animaux sauvages est resté loin de tout
ce que sur lequel vous n'êtes pas sûr si
vous avez 1 2 agissez en conséquence à
savoir que vous soyez plus commander qui
vous soyez plus conservateur que tout
agacé dans l'avion ça prendrait vraiment
les probabilités qu'on a tapé bonheur
dans l'avion sont très minimes chansons
sont très très très minime premièrement
comme vous savez les volants si
quelqu'un est en phase de récupération à
savoir qu'il n'a pas de symptômes
il ne peut pas transmettre teboul au
départ ok alors si pour que vous
transmettiez les bords vous ayez pas
être passager très malade
ok et en provenance d'un pays où il a
été en contact
si ça se produisait mais à ce moment
alors les agents de bord ont des lignes
de conduite à suivre qui vont permettre
de protéger les autres passagers isolés
celui qui semble malade isolé le plus
possible sur le stand malades ou
déplacer les jours ci le différents
types des pandas de la situation parce
qu'une situation pour toujours la même
alors faut s'adapter mais on a
différents types de procédures à suivre
et les agents sont tout à fait au
courant de ces procédures
tout en sachant que ça prend une chose
de l'étude de comparer les chances de
l'équipe biologique
effectivement il faut il faut toucher
par exemple comme vous voyez l'afrique
de l'ouest par des phénomènes
d'enterrement et des cérémonies
d'enterrement où les gens se touchent sa
basse etc
donc c'est très physique sur l avion
c'est rare que vous allez toucher
quelques chauffeurs en accrochant au
passage mais sur ça on transmet pas les
brûlures de cette façon il faut vraiment
en contact avec le passager étroite
n'appuie ces liquides biologiques
c'est la période vous avez été plus
occupé depuis que vous êtes conseiller
américain
oui mais ben je dirais pas avec h1n1 en
2009 ça a été très occupé aussi mais la
grosse différence sa voiture
la période h1n1 quand on a su que la
virulence du virus était pas aussi fort
qu'on croyait au début ça si la lumière
est calme et plus rapidement alors que
maintenant
bon je veux pas pessimiste mais si on
suit ce qui accorde les autorités
publiques du sepa pour contrôler demain
matin ou après demain non je pense que
ça va continuer pour un bon moment
beaucoup j'ai appris